Empire Leicester Square at the heart of
London's entertainment district for over
a century has played host to
star-studded premieres of some of
Hollywood's biggest films now this
iconic venue is home to a world-class
IMAX cinema transforming the original
theater to the IMAX experience was not
without its challenges we're about to
take the projectors in C auditorium and
the only way to do that is the web which
I'm over the top of the building instead
return visit if expected at all weighing
over half a ton the IMAX projection
system was not the easiest thing to
maneuver into the booth temporary ramps
and pulley systems had to be built on
site just to get the projectors into
position to be hoisted up to the
projection booth window the original
theater steeply raked seating back was
up to the standards of IMAX is patented
theater geometry and has been preserved
with new luxury leather seats installed
once the screen frame is built it's time
to hang the imax loudspeakers this
powerful sound system turns the entire
auditorium into a 3d soundscape raising
the IMAX screen is another big job this
screen weighs in at 215 kilos and is 26
and a half meters wide it takes a team
of 20 to carefully unroll the massive
screen and lift it into place the screen
is positioned closer to the audience and
is slightly curved improving the
audience's field of view in this theater
by an impressive 30 degrees to bring you
into the action once all of the
equipment is installed IMAX's technical
team runs several tests to ensure the
system is fully optimized after months
of planning and development the Empire
Leicester Square IMAX is now complete
come check out the difference between
watching a movie
becoming part of one